hi I'm Steve Clemons and I have a
question with neither side willing to
negotiate is the Ukraine war becoming a
Forever War let's get to the bottom line
[Music]
after 10 months of fighting the Ukraine
war has settled into a scary cycle any
Ukrainian Advance on Russian forces in
the East is almost immediately followed
by Russian drone strikes on Ukrainian
infrastructure in the west so besides
the death and the destruction and
displacement of people folks who are
also suffering in freezing temperatures
with no electricity Ukraine insists that
the war is not over until the very last
Russian soldier leaves its territory
Moscow can afford to wait it out because
the fighting isn't on its soil and
Western sanctions haven't crippled the
economy sure the conflict is coming home
for Russians as they hear horror stories
from their own young mobilized mostly
male population on the front lines but
the war machine just rages on meanwhile
U.S President Joe Biden has been able to
spend an average of seven billion
dollars per month on the Ukraine war but
now that the Republicans control
Congress can he keep up the pace next
year or will Ukraine soon have to make
tough compromises and sit down at the
negotiating table today we're taking a
look at the next phase of the war with
Stephen wall professor of international
relations at Harvard University and
author of the hell of Good Intentions
American foreign policy Elite and the
decline of U.S Primacy Steve it's so
great to be with you again this is
always a tough discussion I want to tell
people none of us take what's going on
lightly uh uh but I'm very happy to be
talking to Dr Walt today about what
history tells us at moments like this
what what should we be thinking about
that maybe we're afraid to talk about
about where the Ukrainian war is going
Steve
well I think probably the scariest
Prospect for most of us is that you
won't get the kind of decisive Hollywood
ending that many people would like to
see here I think most of us would like
to see where you get a sort of decisive
humiliating defeat of Russia the United
States and its allies can claim uh you
know a great foreign policy Victory the
ukrainians get all of their territory
back and Russia is uh chastened in the
future by this that's I think what many
people would like to see and the problem
is that well that is I guess still a
remote possibility it's by no means the
most likely possibility I think the most
likely possibility is that you know if
we have this conversation a year from
now Russia is still controlling a
substantial amount of Ukrainian
territory Vladimir Putin is still in
power in Moscow and Ukraine has suffered
another Year's worth of damage that's
not going to look like such a happy
story but it's precisely in situations
like that that each side has to start
rethinking what its War aims are and
start asking whether there is some sort
of political compromise that neither one
is necessarily going to like very much
but it's better than allowing the war to
continue forever well President Biden
has been very hesitant to ask Ukraine to
begin any sort of real negotiations
process but both around the president
but also very top-tier National Security
voices are beginning to say we need
another track one of them is Henry
Kissinger and Henry Kissinger in The
Spectator wrote the time is approaching
to build on the Strategic changes which
have already been accomplished and to
integrate them into a new structure
towards achieving peace through
negotiation
a a representative of President Vladimir
zielinski was very quick to respond he
says all supporters of Simple Solutions
should remember the obvious any
agreement with the devil a bad piece at
the expense of Ukrainian territories
will be a victory for Putin and a recipe
for success for autocrats around the
world and that was Ukrainian
presidential Aid uh mikhailo padoliak
well I I think that frames pretty well
you know two dimensions in in the debate
and I guess one of the questions I have
for you Stephen is America
and NATO so wrapped up in this process
now that we can't be the party that
begins talking about how to seek a
compromise or negotiate are we still
stuck on one side of this that we're no
longer able to see the other side
uh I don't think that's quite true uh
it's it's true that the United States
may not be the best honest broker here
given that we're all in on on one
particular side and there may have to be
third parties that help sort of smooth
the beginnings of this discussion I
might add that the aid that president
zielinski is right this is not going to
be an easy negotiation by any means and
the obstacles to any kind of political
settlement or formidable I mean people
who talk about uh you know going to
peace talks and reaching a solution very
quickly I think have not thought through
clearly just how difficult uh this is
going to be Ukraine has every reason to
want some kind of assurances that this
isn't going to happen again Russia will
undoubtedly have its own desires for
certain assurances so that the things
that helped lead it to start the war in
the first place uh are alleviated and
none of these are going to be easy to
work out at all so I wouldn't be naive
about it but nonetheless the the thing
that's going to drive I think a
consideration of some form of negotiated
settlement is the difficulty that both
sides are going to have in achieving any
kind of decisive breakthrough on the
ground it's quite clear that the initial
Russian war plan was badly designed
their forces mismanaged that they
weren't prepared they made a
miscalculation after miscalculation but
at this point their war effort does
appear to be improving slightly they
have defensible positions that are going
to be hard for the ukrainians to tackle
it's going to be increasingly hard for
either side I think to make a really
decisive gains and yet the pain will
continue and it's at points like that
which sometimes is called a hurting
stalemate that then you get people to
say well okay we're not going to get
everything we might want but what can we
get that we might be able to live with I
don't think we're there yet by the way
but that's I think where this is
ultimately going to end up you know one
of the questions I have is how much pain
are the Russians feeling from this and
recently I met with a gentleman who was
the former Chief of Staff at the German
defense Ministries now working for the
Munich security conference and he's very
adamant that Ukraine will win and will
prevail in this he said that the Russian
soldiers are untrained unprepared they
are while we're seeing pictures of
ukrainians you know freezing in these in
these terrible temperatures because of
hit infrastructure he said the moment Uh
Russian soldiers get wet or their
uniforms aren't aren't managed properly
they will freeze in these temperatures
because they're untrained to know what
to do and I'm just interested at some
certain levels at whether the feedback
coming back into Russia with the
mobilization of so many of its young men
and the battlefield scenes on the
Russian side which are pretty horrific
whether or not from your experience that
matters in a place like Russia that even
if it's not a democracy see in the way
you and I look at it a lot of Russians
still think they are a democracy
um there's no question that you know the
Russian soldiers have suffered uh
enormously and were not particularly
well prepared for this again there are
some indications that they're uh getting
their act together to some degree
um one of the things that's very
frustrating in trying to figure out
where we are in this particular conflict
is that it's hard to know what the
relative balance is on either side I
think we tend to get more upbeat reports
from what's happening on the Ukrainian
side it's hard to get numbers on exactly
what Ukrainian losses have been we hear
a lot about how badly the Russians are
suffering we don't hear as much about
what's happening on the Ukrainian side
apart from the civilian uh suffering uh
that Ukraine is going through and that
makes it really hard to know exactly
what the balance of force is likely to
be it's also just worth remembering
Russia's got three times the population
uh
Putin's mobilization has brought 300 000
more soldiers into the into the meat
grinder how well prepared they're going
to be how well they'll be able to fight
uh remains to be seen it seems to me but
again the Russian uh at this point are
fighting on the defensive and they have
devoted an enormous amount of effort
over the last few months to building
defensive positions in some key areas
whether that will be enough again we
don't know yet uh it would be in some
respects uh what all of us hope for is
if it that turns out not to be effective
what I don't think any of this is going
to do though is cause a fundamental
rethinking in Moscow anytime soon you're
not going to see it seems to be a
popular Uprising I think the combination
of Russian propaganda and the security
forces around Putin are going to be able
to keep the lid on this so even though
it's not particularly popular even
though the conduct of the war gets lots
of criticism in the Russian blogosphere
as well and on email and things like
that I don't think that's going to lead
to the kind of political change in
Russia that will cause an immediate as I
said Hollywood ending to this particular
conflict and I I say take no pleasure
whatsoever in saying that let me put up
some figures of what usaid to Ukraine is
amounting to be in 2022 alone we have
contributed about 68 billion dollars
President Biden has now requested an
additional 37.7 billion dollars and that
would bring the total if approved up to
about 105 billion it's running about
seven billion dollars a month
um to to support Ukraine and as we said
Congress is going to be have a new uh
Dimension uh here shortly in a couple of
weeks and and the Republicans will be
controlling it now to be clear to our
friends Republicans are not
anti-supporting Ukraine some Republicans
are some Democrats are but this may
become more of an issue about whether or
not there is a blank check to supporting
Ukraine and I'm wondering whether you
see where you see that going in terms of
pressure you've advocated that maybe we
need another course maybe we need to
find a way towards a negotiated outcome
of this given the realities but does
that pressure on the financial side help
um well I don't think there's gonna
you're gonna see a congressionally
mandated cut off anytime soon I think
the Congress will give the Biden
Administration uh what it wants at least
for the next uh next few months so I
don't think that's going to be an issue
I do worry about the fact that even uh
with the best will in the world it may
be somewhat more difficult for the West
to include the United States to provide
the levels of support that they've been
able to sustain up until now and that's
in part because we've simply drawn down
a lot of our own ammunition stocks to
provide it to the ukrainians so even if
we want to keep supporting them at the
level we have that may be hard to do
it's sort of the military equivalent of
a supply chain problem
um but the thing that I think worries me
the most is that we still don't have a
completely effective counter and may
never get one uh to the attacks the
Russians have been making on Ukraine
civilian infrastructure and especially
its power grid
um that kind of damage if it eventually
really were to bring down the Ukrainian
power grid is a true catastrophe and
again it's not just undermining
Ukrainian morale at that point you
really have a situation where you know
millions of ukrainians might end up
having to flee the country which is
already an issue for them uh so there
are there are things that could happen
in the next few months again I hope they
do not uh which worry me greatly and are
somewhat independent of you know the
billions of dollars up or down that the
United States is able to provide you
know both your article that appeared
recently in foreign policy magazine I
highly recommended people is called the
perpetually irrational Ukraine debate
but also Henry Kissinger's article in
The Spectator both out very recently
kind of raised this broad issue that
that where we're going right now
um isn't going to work and and to
Kissinger's point he said in World War
one which was a fight about a lot of
things a fight about morality a fight
about you know alliances essentially the
United States at that moment in World
War One eventually became someone who
could come in and come in from the the
side and begin trying to do something
different is there anywhere you know
you're famous in in uh Arab Israeli
talks is there an Oslo out there you
can't use Oslo anymore because they're
now uh uh in in NATO I guess but I mean
is there in a a force out there that
could come by way and begin becoming
part of the scene set the stable set the
dinner bring the parties together and
begin talking about potential
alternative outcomes
um you know I don't think so uh when the
war initially broke out I I thought that
the country that might be able to
perform a role like that was actually
China uh that it had influence with
Russia it uh had a reasonably uh good
standing uh with the ukrainians uh it
wasn't actively involved in the fight
and that Xi Jinping could represent
himself as a independent mediator just
trying to bring peace and score some
great diplomatic points if he were able
to pull that off I think the Chinese
response which has been to sort of
tacitly lean uh in support of the
Russians uh has now removed them from
that role and they're not really
interested in in playing this uh I don't
think there is a third party now that
can essentially come in grab each side
by the Scruff of the neck and say okay
you're going to to make a deal
um it's too politically fraught for the
Biden Administration to try and play
that role I don't think turkey although
it's played a mediating role on some
minor issues connected with the conflict
but it's not in a position doesn't have
the leverage to produce uh the kind of
deal and ultimately this will come down
to the two sides deciding that they are
better off reaching some kind of an
agreement I don't know what form that
agreement would take and that will as I
said earlier involve an awful lot of
complex bargaining over where lines are
going to be drawn the repatriation of
prisoners of reconstruction aid for
Ukraine the whole issue of Ukrainian
neutrality which is one of the reasons
the war started assurances from the
Russian side they're not simply going to
re-arm and start this up again a few
years down the road Etc there's an
enormous number of issues that would
have to be thrashed out here and perhaps
the best one can hope for is a a genuine
Armistice that you know doesn't
necessarily end the quote-unquote
conflict but puts each side in a
position where they don't want to resume
things a number of people I think Gideon
Rockman in the financial times have
recently raised the Korea example
there's still no peace treaty ending the
Korean War fought for three years from
1950 to 1953 but we have had an
Armistice that has held ever since then
and something like that but fashioned
appropriately for the specific
circumstances of Ukraine might be where
we end up here well of course the Korean
war in part depends upon the trigger of
U.S soldiers deployed there in part
including you know the likelihood of a
nuclear uh potential you know option
will come there so that's a sort of
scary scenario to begin thinking about
but I think on another side of it I've
been trying to ask myself you know for
the United States and NATO and I've been
around a lot of officials recently who
are just absolutely adamant that Russia
cannot be given another permission slip
as some people said it was given after
the invasion and annexation of Crimea
that its expansion activities are are
one you know and troubling in the in
parts of Eastern Europe was something
that needed a signal back otherwise if
you don't respond then this problem will
become a larger one do you think there's
logic in that in that argument
I I understand the logic but I'm not
persuaded by it um the idea is that if
somehow uh Russia gets anything out of
this you know even permanent control of
Crimea that we've somehow rewarded
aggression we've somehow given them a
free pass and I think if you look at the
damage that's been done to Russia and
but done to the Russian military it's
quite clear that this is a strategic
defeat for Russia even if they extract
some kind of pyrrhic victory in some
kind of final settlement I mean if you
just consider what this has done to the
Russian economy what it's done to the
Russian military what it's done to
Russia's Global reputation uh Europe
permanently weaning itself off of Russia
oil and gas uh Russia being largely cut
off from the most sophisticated forms of
Western technology or forced to smuggle
them in this is going to have a
long-term negative consequences for
Russia in other words they're paying an
enormous price for what the decision
that Vladimir Putin made so even if they
were to extract some set of concessions
at the end preserve some control of
Crimea or other parts of what was
originally Ukrainian territory again not
something I would like to see happen but
if that were to happen they have paid an
enormous price for it and I don't think
Putin would be eager at any point in
what's left of his life to replay this
kind of experiment again somewhere else
the International Community has in fact
taught the lesson that aggression really
does get penalized and it really doesn't
pay even if again there's some kind of
compromise deal that ends the war you
and I have discussed China before and
China as a much more serious
geostrategic challenge to the United
States and and allies what do you think
China is learning from this lesson are
they seeing in America and a NATO that
are willing to engage more deeply than
they had or they see seeing us trapped
in a strategic you know pit that we
can't extract ourselves from
well I'm sure there are a range of
Chinese interpretations of what's going
on here but I think there are several
lessons they ought to be drawing one is
that even uh you know uh sophisticated
or well-prepared militaries uh sometimes
screw up uh and in fact elaborate
military plans don't always go the way
you expect them to so that suggests a
conventional military assault on Taiwan
which would be difficult in the best of
circumstances is something they ought to
really not consider or at least not
assume would go smoothly that's lesson
number one lesson number two is the one
you alluded to that in fact the
International Community tends to respond
very vigorously to acts of unprovoked
aggression and a Chinese Assault on
Taiwan would be seen in that light so
the assumption that there would be
disarray that America's Asian Partners
would uh you know not know how to
respond the idea that NATO would not
react perhaps even in an Asian context
all of those things are are things that
I think the Chinese would not you know
we should take these are the lessons the
Chinese should observe from this there
was more life left in the Western
Alliance than they may have believed
however the the third part of this is
that the longer this war goes on the
better it probably is for China right
and a huge distraction it takes enormous
amount of bandwidth it is consuming
American resources and Western resources
that could be used for other purposes so
in a Chinese context in some L and one
final thing it's making Russia more
dependent upon China and ultimately a
more compliant Ally so if you are
looking for a grand strategic imperative
to try and bring the war to an end
sooner rather than later it's also so
that the United States can focus on what
is the longer geostrategic challenge
which is China not Russia you know
recently uh Steve I interviewed the
incoming chair of the house Commerce and
energy committee Kathy McMorris Rogers
and I asked her about where her support
for Ukraine was and how much were her
own constituents willing to tolerate
high prices shortages Etc down the road
potentially related to the crisis and
her response was you know my people
really don't want to see prices continue
to go up inflation is really hurting
them and and she still of course
sympathetic and empathetic on the
Ukraine front but it raises the
interesting question of uh how the what
the future is going to look like we're
seeing you know a global food security
crisis we're seeing uh energy weaponized
we're seeing authoritarianism popular
you know populism Etc in reaction to
some of these how messy a year or a
couple of years do you see ahead as a
result of a crisis like this one
yeah there you know as you know there
have been there's been some good news on
the inflation front at least here in the
United States less so in other parts of
the world uh so that's something we may
hope you know continues
um but I think you've put your finger on
what is a real problem now if we do end
up with a stalemate uh in Ukraine and
that is it's one thing to get uh people
in other countries to make sacrifices in
the short term if they think those
sacrifices are going to pay off
um it's much harder to get people to
continue to make the same sacrifices
when it appears to be kind of open-ended
that this is not ultimately going to get
resolved anytime soon are we going to
have to do this for years uh two three
years four years I mean you and I saw
the same problem with the so-called
forever wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
even when there's public support
initially for them if you don't have the
prospect of success uh down the road
it's much harder to get people to
continue to Pony up and then it makes it
even worse of course if condition at
home become more difficult I think this
is something actually the Ukrainian
government is well aware of which is one
of the reasons they have been trying to
tout you know recent military successes
and I think are hoping for more because
the more they can demonstrate that you
know momentum is on their side and this
isn't going to take forever the more
likely Western support is to be
sustained the difficulty is I think the
military challenge for them is actually
going to get harder not easier in the
future and then the domestic
considerations that you just raised are
going to kick in more powerfully
well Stephen Walt Harvard University
professor of international relations
thank you for your candor thanks so much
for being with us today
great talking with you as always Steve
so what's the bottom line ending the war
in Ukraine is a tough decision for the
Western allies they feel that they
didn't do enough in 2014 when Russia
annexed Crimea and that kind of gave
Russian President Vladimir Putin a
permission slip in my view to try to
roll over the rest of the country now
the U.S and the other NATO Nations have
made Ukraine which was not an ally and
that has to be noted the defining
challenge for themselves that means
their own self-image and their own sense
of security is also wrapped up in the
fate of Ukraine but how long will
Americans accept to pump money and
weapons into this cause if it becomes a
Forever War American and European
support is bound to wither so what
should Ukraine do it's damned if it
compromises and damned if it doesn't and
both options have very tragic
consequences so as we head into a new
year we have nothing to look forward to
but a slow slog of back and forth
victories and tragedies in freezing
temperatures sadly this war seems
nowhere near to an end and that's the
bottom line
foreign
[Music]